I have an expiration date she has an
expiration date time my expiration days
may 1st 2013 right now Nathalie Gautier
runs La Petite sir can Ariel and circus
arts training program in Culver City
California it's one of the only of its
kind and people come from around the
world to give their kids the chance to
work with Natalie that you've come from
Australia we arrived last Sunday we've
come over especially for their workshop
it was just too good an opportunity for
my son to miss out on besides her work
another important part of Natalie's life
is her longtime partner Hope Hall how
long have you been together six years
and we're engaged
and we're engaged but it's on the wrong
finger I have to get it signed I know I
miss sized it because well I this just
happened it's really sweet it's a
beautiful ring thank you she was really
nervous
nataly's work as a talent agent brought
her to the u.s. seventeen years ago with
an impressive roster of young canadian
actors including hayden christensen and
Elisha Cuthbert since then she's run
several successful businesses including
her wildly successful entrepreneur
homeowner faithful partner in almost
every way natalie is the embodiment of
the American dream except for one
crucial detail she's not an American
citizen I go to bed at night I get a new
expiration date so I'm always a guest in
this country the reason I panic so much
is four years ago my visa did expire and
I had I had a serious injury I'm a
trapeze artist and when I had the injury
I had to have surgery I was asked to
leave the country and here I was already
successful as I was I was locked out for
like five six weeks with you know one
pair of underwear one shirt you know it
was horrible I was here alone
Natalie currently holds an o1 visa which
is only granted to a select group of
people a year and is for so-called
aliens of extraordinary ability while
Natalie's accomplishments are certainly
extraordinary she still has to waste her
time and thousands of dollars every time
her visa is set to expire do you feel
like a US citizen this is my home this
is where this is where I work this is
where I employ 16 Americans this is
where I pay all of my taxes I'm very
grateful that I have an o1 visa but I
have to keep renewing it and I have to
keep proving myself every 24 months and
it takes six to nine months of paperwork
to do so and it costs thousands and
thousands of dollars not only does the
current immigration system create
seemingly insurmountable barriers to
citizenship for productive workers like
Natalie it also discriminates against
her let's
about this and you know blunt terms if
she were a man you would get married
need to have your green card yes I I
could go tomorrow to the local prison
and marry a piece of the male anatomy it
was like that someone who's really a
convict a criminal who's male and I
would get my green card within six to
eight months but it would be a sham it
would be alive while President Obama had
kind words to say about gay marriage in
recent months it is important for me to
go ahead and affirm that I think
same-sex couples should be able to get
married the fact is that the Defense of
Marriage Act remains the law of the land
and under DOMA the federal government
cannot recognize same-sex marriage while
marriage is a ticket to citizenship for
straight couples that's not the case for
gay couples even if they are married in
a state where it's legal the system is
based on an assumption that if you want
to stay long term because of a family
relationship that you'll be able to use
that family relationship to stay
permanently and that's true but not for
gay people
Rachel tivan is an attorney and director
of a group called immigration equality
she says that gay couples deserve the
same treatment under federal law as
straight couples our federal system is
based on States making determinations
about family law the Defense of Marriage
Act says that for gay people and gay
people only the state can't make that
determination I believe that government
as a whole has an interest in marriage
because we have an interest in children
in the future and that necessarily
includes both the federal government and
state government
Austin amok is senior counsel with the
Alliance defending freedom and has
defended DOMA in front of Congress the
reason we allow married people to
immigrate to the country and provide
citizenship in an opposite-sex context
because there's a man and a woman most
times there's children involved and we
want to make sure and maintain the unity
of that fam
unit we can keep them intact the
principle was undermined in the same sex
context to really answer the question of
how same-sex couples or lesbian and gay
immigrants are treated by the American
immigration system you actually have to
go back historically to 50 years in
which gay people were barred from
entering the country so you could be
asked under American immigration law are
you a homosexual are you a sex pervert
what's the language that was used for a
long time and if you said yes or if
immigration and officials thought that
the answer were yes you were not allowed
to enter the country whether it's
outright discrimination or a misguided
attempt by the government to protect
Children and Families Natalie in the
hope see the immigration system is
fundamentally unfair certainly she could
grant me Canadian citizenship over a
weekend I mean it's
conversely here in the US because gay
marriage is not federal I can't offer
her that same gift and it kills me I
served in the military I'm a graduate of
the Naval Academy I have served this
country and I deserve the same rights
and those rights include the ability to
give the person I love that gift and it
angers me
and hope isn't the only one angered by
what's happening to Natalie
I mean this study was gone this studio
would be gone the kids won't be here
anymore we won't be here anymore she's
changed so many people's lives and if
she couldn't say her I don't know what
anyone in this room would do I just
wanted I just wanted to have my
residency and I'd love to have them I
just it just angers me that I can't I I
can just lie to the government and and
marry a man but I don't want to do that
I don't want to lie I want to be honest